I already hear me it has been a great
honor to be invited as he knows my name
is Xiao Han le the data science team and
Lucie works so they say Lucia versus
search and tax analytics software
company and then we're bringing more and
more deep learning stuff you know or
software so today I'd like to talk about
deep learning as we all know deep
learning in the past few years has
attract a lot of attention and being
disruptive to conventional machine
learning but the matters and then
techniques are totally different from
traditional methods
what's the connections and differences
what's the voltage and difficulties so
today I like its opportunity to do some
hours in comparison of deep learning
method versus traditional machine
learning and pair with three different
case studies in the areas of sentiment
analysis question answering system and a
healthcare image classification okay
let's get started so the close closest
relative of deep neural network is of
course the traditional neural network
team your networks the type of neural
network but at the surface level a
tradition neural network like this in
the bottom you really only have up to a
few layers but if you look at a current
deep neural network so I'd like to start
with the convolutional neural I worked
with where the difference started so a
deep convolutional neural network can
range the hidden layers increase from a
few to a dozen and some of the residual
Network and even have 30 to 50 hidden
layers so but problem arose when you
increase the number of layers suppose we
use fully connected layer and then
making 30 such layers and you'll find
you have a memory explosion to Train so
many parameters and then the gradient
can all pass through so many layers so
architectural a the deep learning
researcher making some changes started
using
convolution layers income illusion
layers so the the later layers only
connected to a small region of the input
neurons and then it's kind of do
summarization and after convolutional
layers people use maps pooling to
provide more condensed the feature map
on the or ISM site in conventional
neural networks you can see the learning
rates decrease throughout the layers
which means the later layer don't have
picking up gradient to learn if you keep
doing the propagation so our sign in
addition to the tradition is et and
barber back propagation people do some
changes for example they replace some of
the activation function from Sigma and
attending to relu to deal with this kind
of gradient vanishing problem also one
problems with relu is like the opera
Braille you don't have upper limit then
it will introduce an album called
blowing out so another techniques called
patch nomination they've become popular
and you can see when we have a lot of
layers there were tons of exponential in
many trainable parameters nicely easily
to overfit so another relatively new
techniques cultural power is introduced
as we can see we have to use all these
type of techniques to make deep neural
network so then why bother to deal with
these trouble to make a new network deep
what's the benefit there there are few
famous theory one of them is like the
ability to learn hierarchies of concepts
and building up multiple layers of
abstraction this is also the way a lot
of real-world data is constructed
especially for image and tax for example
the picture on the first part shows how
CN network and find features of a
picture and if we do some activation to
see the activation I each layer you can
find that a low
layers with them for the first
convolution layer can detect edge and
block then the later layered attack
combination of action block become
texture the objects parts and last can
based on the object class do the
prediction and similarly if we apply a
one-dimensional collusion network to the
text data then we can try different
window size for the future basically
find different immigrants like three
grams two gram flour grams and then
basically you're trying to find the
phrases none at higher layer combine the
phrases at the sentence level now at a
paragraph level at document level and in
the end to the prediction and also it's
becoming more and more popular people
don't apply the network directly on the
world level they go to a lower level at
the character level so it's like you
apply a ceiling at a careful level
you'll find like the first layer people
can detect the some worse surfaces like
morphology of spaces and at a later
level can find word rules basically part
of speech information such as detecting
it's the articles or pronouns now later
combining two words and then since it's
at a character level we can do some kind
of combination then your dish in the
words it can combine to finding common
misspellings also happy nation's and
conquer nations then we go to the world
level for each level sentence level so
the second benefit is it has been shown
like a deep network and compute be able
to compute any kind of complex functions
so this is allergy like a magic holder
from Mecca nuisance near neck and deep
learning book so he using example
suppose you given a task to design
computer from scratch and you only given
a limited number of circuits and you
find it's it's really hard to do much
with shallow layers of circuits because
we find even simple calculation tasks if
multiple layers of
assembly so while you have multiple
layers it's easier to do all kinds of
complicated computation so the third one
people always talking about is like you
don't need to do much manual feature
engineering you know deep neural network
for example you know traditional
computer vision people have to use this
kind of fix the value mask and then
applied it to the original picture and
then each mask can detect a different
kind of features with ample this mask
because it's like have positive value on
the left and acting on the right and
then who applied it into a summary and
then you will find where it had work on
edges but in order to do a complicated
task with ample to do face detection the
traditional community on how to apply a
series of predefined filters to classify
a face which means that you have
manually construct in features and maybe
some of the features it's non leading in
the model but in a collisional network
those shared ways and biases faces the
convolutional filters a computer with
internet or through the training so
personally I think signal
so personally I think one of the most
important benefit of within your network
it's not just no manual feature
engineers needed it's actually the
feature generation optimization and
evaluation was build within the same
network because a lot of times do my
based on my experience it's very
important to find the right combinations
of feature and Daniel classification on
classic master for example we're trying
to do some tests or clustering at Lucy
works and I find like a tf-idf usually
works well with hierarchical clustering
but not well with k-means because Khmer
means cannot you with outlier so it's
not about which not just about which
classification measure you use it's
about the right combination but if we
try to fit everything together and then
train the network so that can find the
sweet spots and the right combination is
more likely it can provide superior
results and last but not least and your
network architecture itself is pretty
flexible when we make a deep we have
more room to make all kinds of changes
at different places it's just a lack of
Lego and now you can do all kind of
combination for example our currently a
state of art named entity recognition
methods it's using Ceylon on the front
to detect a character level and world
level features then feeding to Alice ATM
Bay same with high power n to learn
information throughout the whole the
whole sequence so you can combine
different character at different places
also you can add like a promotable
output to predict one one a month more
than one thing and has been shown like a
certain task the prediction accuracy of
some network
in one up who can beat a single tax
alert network also if you can find
essential features from the improve by
building the embodying to predict
multiple things well that means when you
extract the inviting labor out and the
inbreeding layer is pretty
representative and you can use those
layer to do other things
that's basically the the fundamental
idea of a Google sentence encoder which
is published last year okay after seeing
the benefits of deep network the the
deep learning researchers is trying to
make a deep neural network reliable by
applying different techniques but if you
see it you can see many techniques
directly borrowed from traditional
machine learning as I mentioned the
convolutional filtering is it's a human
taking traditional computation and the
inclusion of innovation people use all
kind of pooling methods and max pooling
is just aware of them freedom for the
users fully mastered in spatial pyramid
matching for image compression purposes
also the regular fluoridation masters l1
l2 norm is a revelation was using deep
learning but as a pretty popular in
regression last election night and data
harmonization was frequently using
traditional consideration to also their
subtracting in deep learning called
noise injection you can inject noise to
waste then it's basic Estill castle
implementation of Bayesian inference now
if we inject over top holes this master
has been using so 1980s to in
traditional motion learning we early
plot the charts of training and
validation data of ROC curve and see the
gap and then also in patient we monitor
the parameter converges and not very
stopping in different it's basically a
programmatic implementation of such
matters and I embedded
in the new network itself an elimination
site STD and back propagation has been
used in tradition your network and then
the most popular cost function is still
cross-entropy and MSE e
& hué new learning rate is it's pretty
essential in traditional network to and
as I mentioned in the first Slyke there
are a few around new techniques such as
draw power relu and bash thermalization
but if we look into those ideas are none
of them not wholly new so if you catch
our jatha was invented in 2014 so what
it does is randomly removing the hidden
layers by random applying like applying
a zero mask at different iterations and
then it's kind of equivalent to bagging
with bootstrapping training data so if
we talk about bagging by randomly
district features and bootstrap inputs
and the first thing come to mind it can
be random forests so they are both doing
constructing on data points and bagging
on features but and then also following
the same principle that is a group of
wake learners can come together to form
a stronger learner but the differences
here is like what random force do is to
distract the input data but drop out ooh
is this destructor hiding layers which
means destroyed extracted features so
it's still a loss snacker learned eco
input distribution another difference is
like a random force is doing the packing
and bootstrapping literally it's random
sample input data and then [ __ ] model
each model and make them convergence and
ensemble later at the last step but job
is doing the some masking
at random at each iteration so is
everything is done in the in the same
network in the whole training process so
it's a kind of approximation to extreme
exponentially many
networks so it's a relatively a
collaborative and let's look at relu so
people starting to looking for a new
activation function because one we do a
deep neural networks the gradient will
decrease over the layers so if we look
at a traditional activation function for
example this is the activation function
called sigmoid it has a range of from 0
to 1 so it has a squashing of fact so if
you do this activation function your
gradient will become smaller lower order
layers that's why people change it from
rather to so same way to rattle so this
is the function of rattle so it's
basically max 0 and X and then you don't
have an upper limit on the right side so
it can reduce the gradient banishing
problem improving convergence and it's
still since it's a nonlinear function so
it can still introduce non-energy
it's also faster to compute but if you
look at this function this is nothing
but but of hinge function and I think
function is has been used for for a long
time and and one of my favorite
tradition emotional methods called Mars
multivariate adaptive regression spline
and Marcia especially using a pair of
key function to track a nonlinear
relationship between marbles and it's
it's a pretty good algorithm contraption
non-linearity also provide a relatively
higher accuracy than obvious question
actually this hinge function has to
appear as I said long time ago the
reason like the tradition no your lab
were researcher didn't use it because
you can see there's no upper limit of
this function and then it will have some
blowing up problem which means the Alpha
layer
don't have our upper limit it will
provide all kinds of January all kinds
of ill-conditioned mathematics issues so
that's why people have to introduce
another master called a batch
normalization to deal with this growing
our problem
so what Bosch normalization to is like
you know deep neural network we do
pre-processing specifically normalized
to zero mean and unit variance and every
layer of new tomorrow for every mini
patch the benefits as I said in life
forcing Monte to deal with the global
problem also a can a per why either
weight initialization and learning rate
setup if we use it but a normalization
is such a common hanging to use in
machine learning for example in
tradition your network the learning rate
depends on you improve value a smaller
info will typically require a larger
ways so if we do the standardization
then we can just use one single learning
rate to train a model it's easier to set
up also in a lot of machinery master
such a classroom regression or SVM
normalization is your is suggested to
because it can make sure warbles with
the larger value will overpower the
warbles with a smaller value also
normalization across batches was using
machine learning to the problem called
coherent shift especially in some a
column econometrics regression problem
because the distribution of marbles can
be different between training and
housing when market condition change
when you do the back testing so if
rescue is throughout different time then
we can make sure the training and
testing data are comparable okay after
comparing our ISM let's see the
comparison of deep learning versus
machine learning
a few case studies the first case study
I like to talk about it's a question
I'll share system for insurance
enquiries this is the project we did at
Lucy works so we got a dataset called
insurance QA online it's basically a 20k
Question and Answer pairs generally from
historical frequently asked questions or
support a key record in insurance domain
and the goal is to build a question
answering system to directly recommend
answers from this existing ethical pool
or find similar questions after before
then the business impact is like if we
put this question answer system engine
on a help page or contact us or page
then people can directly find the
answers then it can largely reduced the
call center workload also it can
facility the call center supporting
because people can directly refer to a
solve the problem before the experiment
we take here we come here deep learning
model versus actually boost the model
especially query pushing tree versus I
super and supervise the worry buddy
so as you can see the traditional
machine learning actually boosts model
we have to manually build a set of NLP
features the typical one is like a
cosine score between here very a vector
of the original question announcer or
the question announcer after extracting
only known suburbs and I extract a
question keywords the power of speech
tag an ER tag also we find one
particular warble is specifically
important it's like we apply a mutual
information to extract a question
keywords Association pairs so this is
one of the in front of marble also we
add the word to work embedding also
talked about embedding to build this
whole octopus tree so this is the
architecture of our deep learning model
here we utilize the triplet basis Yama
Steve new network
since this is a triplet a model what we
did is like how when we construct a
training data we already have the
question and the relative answer peers
and we use them as a positive example
also we randomly January 15 irrelevant
answers for each question and pretty as
an active sample and the modeling part
each question answer is encoded to the
same vector space using this encoder
then we compute a cosine distance
between question vector and answer
vectors and then comparing the triplet
loss function to penalise irrelevant QA
pairs and make sure the question and the
relevant answers are close to each other
as possible so this is a details of our
encoder so we followed these steps
before when that hat saw me with first
do the tokenization trim the taxing to
worse then the tokens map to our indexes
you know embedding layer so in this
inviting layer we use the pre-trained
the facet haxing embedding with arnold
online and this embedding is trained
using Wikipedia and some common core
pers data set and since this faster
inviting have a lot of parameters so we
don't want this existing in heading to
overpower the whole network so we apply
a drop out a special one you drop out
right next to the embedding and then
next we use LST M bidirectionality or
it's type of Ireland to trying to
compute the deep complex features for
each of the word and at the pooling
layer instead of using the general
global cooling we find attention
weighted average is a better
summarization matter here and at last
the Alpha we care is a final test
lecture which did representation of the
regional tax
so after we got this encoder we can
encode our existing answers and index
them offline then at at the runtime at
the cure time one a new question coming
and we included two the same vector
space using this encoder and find years
neighbors to rewrite the answers and as
a bonus byproduct of the proposal
training since we got this encoder we
can also apply the same workflow to
react existing questions and then will
be Gary's like a finding similar
question question two questions similar
so here I like to give two examples of
the result of 14 new network and suite
here's a question can my wife drive on
my interest and you can see the answer
for songs or the first few answer is
pretty relevant and then on the left you
you can see this is the similar question
we found and interestingly without using
any single name input or constructing
any URL POS the deep learning model is
able to find us in semantic interesting
similar words so the question is can my
wife throw my insurance and then find
similar question does my husband have to
be on my car insurance how about my
spouse my girlfriend even my ex-wife so
it's like it can find very similar
questions and another example it's not
is it compositor to have home insurance
enables fun is it mandatory to have home
insurance is it a legal requirement to
have home insurance so it's like one
people trying to use this
question-answer system in your real life
they can use all kind of wording and is
still able to find out the answer
themselves here is the evaluation part
of this study since we want to compare
and super as master compare actually
boosts
what we did is like we also test the
model stability by varying size of the
training data the 100% of training data
is about 20k but we like subsample if
50% of
and 10% only have about 2,000
question-answering pairs few Confucians
here you can see the superest method is
overall much better than unsupervised
semester and the deep learning model for
the one there's a 100% of data use the
deep learning model provides the best
results and then you can see it's like I
have a big margin compared to just
actually push the model another exercise
with data is like we take the output of
a different model and use that as a one
of the input for this actually boosah
model it's kind of doing the ensemble
here we can see one there's a 100% of
data so there's no improvement by doing
this an example which is telling us the
deeper model is kind of self-contained
which you don't need to feed in
additional in yarn a'pieu as a synonym
and deploring can do it well itself but
while we doing sampling the 10% of data
you can see the deep learning model
itself is still better than actually
puts the model alone even there's just
2,000 pairs which is a little surprising
to us because we thought deep learning
is pretty like a need a lot of data I
think part of reason here is like we we
use a printer and inviting the facet as
embodying and then leverage existing
with opinion knowledge there so if we
don't use them I think for sure we'll
need more data and last last conclusion
here is like one there's 10% of the you
know the best model we got is using this
ensemble actually boosts a positive
learning which means one we don't have
that enough data we can borrow the
information from any RMP us those
manually extractors and LP features but
it's not recommended it because the
doubled effort of training also
increased
time alright so the second case study is
about sentiment analysis this another
project with data Alison works
we got a fifty million Prada review from
Amazon with customer ratings range from
one to five stars and then we basically
perform five class classification and
then we want to compare a deep learning
model with such traditional model like
largest regression random forest and
naive Bayes so this is the architecture
of a deep learning model you can see
it's very similar to the question
answering system model the reason we're
still using our loom here they say oh
STM rather than us you know because we
found like Ireland is much easier to
tune it's like just apply a little bit
yuning the the our model can be pretty
good and then if you do have it unique
and achieve state of art but if your
ceiling model if you don't you and
carefully it can provide pretty bad
results so but a stability is a pretty
important for self-aware building so we
here we still use LLC m and similarly
using embodying a special job pub here
instead of just using one layer
bidirectional STM we used truly or by
the addition to make it more expressive
and then conk add them together and then
apply attention they were to an elastic
at that that's output to predict the
sentiment one extra thing we do is like
how here we don't just output one thing
so the settlement is one output the
other output is like we output the
attention ways so if you output the
attention ways a benefit you get is like
the attention layer basically telling
you why certain words the important for
certain prediction so if you extract
attention weights out and then do some
color on top of it it can show you
why this is a best sentiment for example
for this sentence websites stock status
is not accurate poor customer service
and then not and poor have higher values
here and then if we do this coloring on
top of you you I you can make the whole
thing more explainable and then people
klingspor in the UI
another thing we observe is like the
deep learning model is able to capture
contextual information pretty well with
a mother's were sentencing this is
awfully good even there so we're awful
unit if we say this is awful then it's
an active but since awfully is connected
with good so the deep learning model is
able to score a pretty high sense
sentiment score and then another example
the products okay overall five stars
nine it's a positive sentiment if you
just change one word say the part is
okay over our two stars then the
different model is pretty sensitive and
then say this is a negative sentiment on
the evaluation part we use the same test
aside from this Amazon review and you
can see the deep learning model win the
best traditional machine learning model
by a large part the best model model is
naive Bayes and another thing which has
here is since sentiment analysis is kind
of generalizable tasks because people
use similar kind of sentiment were to
describe things we apply this deep
learning model and to test the
generalization using a different company
review did a survey download online and
we can see I foreign value is still
above ninety percent so it's a pretty
stable model a lot so quickly I like to
show a kind of toy project
using a kegel data set so this data set
is six thousand cervical cancer images
which labels which belongs to three
types and we're trying to predict three
type of cancers based on the picture
people take in surgery i roughly did
some traditional computer vision method
specifically using the visual bag of
words with safety features and feeding
into as we m so basic instructor safety
features and use k-means to build a code
book and then build a histogram and feed
the image histogram into SVM and on the
deep learning site since 6000 image is
not enough to build a class like a whole
different network from scratch so a lot
of people borrow the existing training
neural network from wordnet for example
resident 34 is the one I use I saw
people use bgt 16 and then what you can
do is you utilize this fridge for n
convolutional layers and then lock after
fully connected layers and replace with
your own data set and do transfer
learning on the your problem at hand and
you can see the different model or other
- value is not high because for this is
that even with my own lies I cannot tell
the difference of those three classes
the deeper model still like a window
traditional method by a large margin and
based on my observation it can did have
very subtle difference between the
pictures also if you apply the
organization exact one can also improve
a lot because they can deal with things
like rotation better if you apply the
augmentation
okay we have seen case studies and our
comparisons and you can see based on
case study the deep learning can easily
be previously there are machine learning
models and then is the early if you
calico winners the euro you steep
learning to win the accommodation but uh
we'd haven't heard like there's a large
skill enterprise adaptation of the deep
learning that much I think in summary
there's some issues with deep learning
the first one there's a huge number of
possible settings if you if it's a deep
neural network there's all kind of
possible architecture you can use you
have to decide the number of layers the
filters future size where to put your
pod and also there's a large number of
hyper parameters common learning rate
epochs I mean besides and some have a
pair answers even have its own hyper
parameters
another issue with summer many hyper
parameters and masters are actually
related for example the masters have
recognized vision effect including
convolution a one-hour to chop our loop
as a fashion alarm or stopping all these
can do regularization so then I don't
know if I already apply the dropout or I
want our two noms you and Hitler is
talking or not so the only thing to tell
is to experiment and try there's also
the generalization problem the the image
Tiffany or Nara have been a to do Co job
doing transfer learning but the transfer
learning from an LPS you in the very
early stage there's last year there are
some publications we try some methods it
doesn't really work and but if you
borrow the preacher and convolution
layer in the image problem you can save
a lot of training time but it's hard to
control and understand and easy to
overfit to also it's been famous at deep
learning is pretty like
computing resource hungry so for example
google claim have a auto
engine can automatically tune the model
for you but if they train a lot of image
from scratch they may need 800 gigabytes
or GPUs run for a week unless you will
company have a big GPO farm I don't
think a small company can do that also
it's ok the debugging for a deep
learning network can take a while
especially given the current packages
it's not that friendly to use I lost as
a deep learning practitioner I wish a
few errors can be paid more attention to
for example again deep learning is data
hungry most of the winning method image
classification is to supervised learning
masters but labeling a deep learning
living image even just pulling bounding
balls can be quite labor some the other
encoder and again is a good start though
but I hope there's can be more and super
id planning research come out also deep
learning on small data how to deal with
all active active learning it's like
help you choose which example people
should label rather than label
everything on the Jeremias Asian site a
lot of exercises now people using pre
trained embeddings and initialize the
network but for them for the QA system
we apply the same network like coding
question they decide and we found like a
half of the wordix Auto vocabulary
because the coding the code it's not
capturing in Wikipedia and how do you
with that kind of problem to to to map
different were spaces also deep learning
is famous on image and the text data
because image has and hacks itself have
a lot of structure itself although it's
called unstructured data because is from
the traditional database domain and
therefore the tabular data hollowed you
with mixture of different data types and
how to deal with explain ability for tax
for the tabular data it's a big question
so that's why it's kind of rare to see
deep learning in some regular life area
such as recent management or clinical
trial when when the OCC or FDA require
the model to be explainable than nobody
you'll steep learning on the package
side as a data scientists we really like
height Wars because the API is much more
friendly than tensorflow
but our data engineer like tensorflow
because it's easy to paralyze have have
low latency and I has a friendly like
Java API for them to use so I think
eventually one of them may win and then
it's easier for us to choose sorrowful
those complaints so although deep
learning is in its early stage and have
a different kind of problem for overall
I feel pretty lucky that we are the
generation that can witness or even
participate in those new breakthroughs
and then we can tell our kids like we're
degenerate and start a self-driving car
or things like that
the last page there's some references
for like for beginners things that's how
I started deep learning
any questions
[Applause]